unitybrite on 8 news now is sponsored by
Our Community Pride Partners Finley
Automotive Group Southwest Medical part
of Optum care and Silver State Schools
Credit Union
well national day of giving is November
29th and Findlay automotive the sponsors
of today's segment is showing their
support to the just one project and
joining us today we have Tyler Corder
from Findlay automotive alongside Leslie
Marshall from the just one project thank
you both so much for joining us it's
great to be here so Taylor I'll start
with you let's talk a little bit about
how important it is for Findlay
automotive to be involved in the
community and just kind of give back to
you know all of your customers yeah so
it's one of the pillars of what we do is
we really like to be involved in the
community and try to make it a little
bit better place for our customers and
our employees that all live here and so
with this national day of giving we
thought you know what's a great charity
in town that we could feature and so the
first one that came to mind was the just
one project because it's a it's a great
charity that helps in a lot of ways
mostly in feeding people that need that
are hungry but it also provides
volunteer opportunities and that's what
I really like about it is people want to
get involved with the charity in town
that just one project is perfect so
that's why I wanted to bring on Leslie
let's talk a little bit about what the
just one project does yeah Leslie I have
worked with the just one project in the
past I know how much you guys do for the
community but tell us a little bit about
your mission and you know how we can all
get involved we are a largest mobile
food pantry and we are founded on
volunteerism so we love when people are
like oh we're volunteering this weekend
um and so we have all those
opportunities for people Monday through
Friday to come and feed in our
wraparound Services pack bags for our
seniors those are the most impacted and
then we also have every third Saturday
where we're able to have everybody come
out to different locations all over the
Vegas Valley with those food insecure
areas and be able to impact over 8 000
to 10 000 families it's really amazing
and we love the fact that our community
comes out and represents we really truly
need Community Partners just like you
and it's great because Casey has a
really great our CEO has a really great
relationship with you guys
um in those UNLV deep Las Vegas routes
that we all have so we're really
grateful and it's totally needed yeah
and for this national day of giving you
know we're in the holiday season now it
feels great to give back to the
community and just for you how does it
feel to to be a part of this and
throughout the year but especially right
now in the holidays yes especially now
and one of the reasons we wanted to talk
about just one project is our employees
go out we've had them out and
volunteered at just one project and
helped package up meals and distribute
meals they come back just you know
really encouraged and excited about the
opportunity to do something in the
community that's why I think it's
awesome anybody that's watching that has
an idea about maybe I could get involved
some way this is perfect you come back
and it's it's as good for you as it is
for the community that you're helping
and so that's why we really like the
just one project and encourage people to
get involved absolutely well Tyler
Leslie thank you so much for everything
you're doing in the community and for
everyone out there it's really important
to support especially on this national
day of giving on November 29th but also
throughout the entire year so thank you
both so much for being here we want to
thank Finley Automotive Group for being
one of our Our Community Pride Partners
Las Vegas now will be